is balance
and to solely provide on a man if i'm
not having kids and i'm not doing
anything well
that would kind of make me lazy
he's getting the short end of the stick
so i have a question what do you guys
feel like you could bring to a guy that
he couldn't just hire a maid and a
hooker to do
that's a good i made a cook and a hooker
to do
so basically you need kids kids
kids is the only thing yeah i'm sorry to
interrupt but it's kids yeah because
i feel like you have to match his energy
like if you if you're trying to chase
someone that has got all this drive and
ambition to be the best and they're
putting in the hours at work you also
need to be of a similar
person like you need to have that
similar personality no because men men
and women look for different things so
like men don't care about your money
they don't care about your career they
don't give away no they don't care about
they don't care about what you do but i
think you still need to do that for
yourself i mean you can do what makes
you happy yeah but it doesn't but no
that's terrified
so you're right you're right actually
you're correct you're correct but i'm
saying like like don't complain about
the results though
so if you want to do what makes you
happy don't complain about the results
yeah so like i mean you can you can you
can like become the guy
but like men don't like guys they're
like women that are like men like guys
no you don't need two yings
yeah they won't fit together or two
yangs it don't work it's yang again so
your question was what do we bring to
the table yeah
yeah a man who can't get from a maid or
yeah like from a from a made like a made
cook and a hooker a paid service i was
gonna you know some hookers provide
emotional safety and intimacy
companionship there are loads of men
that i talk to that are like
linda do you know what sometimes i think
my partner doesn't understand that i
need someone to talk to i need someone
who i can feel vulnerable to
without her throwing it back in my face
yo all right so
you said
men shouldn't um they they are they go
to their women or they're they're
worried about wait say that i'm sorry
so basic wait what
so
i think what they will yeah the
vulnerability they want to
they want their partner to they want to
feel safe to be vulnerable without her
throwing it back in their face when they
have an argument okay so those men
should not be
emotional to their women because it's in
female nature to
if let's say there's an argument between
a man and a woman
if she has ammo
there is no line that she wants she she
won't cross
and
men arguing between men there are lines
they understand i cannot respect exactly
i can't speak about his mother otherwise
all wall breakers however if i'm arguing
with a woman
and she goes say sad about my mom and
her cooking and the last time she said
she she came over there's no boundaries
and so the solution is that men should
go and speak to their male friends
about situations that are
emotional to them that are
deep to them
and then once they've come up with
solutions with their male friends they
should go and have the solutions ready
for their woman ish that's easier said
than done because i agree i actually ran
a room on this on clubhouse about this
whole dynamic and men also said that
they don't always feel safe to speak
about really emotional things because
they don't even know how
because it makes them feel less of a guy
in front of their guy
that's not really your guys
that's not your game
then my solution to that is if you don't
feel com comfortable having a
conversation with your guy friends then
go to an elder like
this is an encore father figure where
they're not in the same
dynamic or group settings
they've done life they've been there
done that got the t-shirt and that way
you can have a conversation with them
that will allow you to feel that oh even
if i i i can feel less of a man if i'm
talking to a guy that's been there he's
he's done things that i could never
imagine do you know what i'm saying
that's what so what so if a guy doesn't
want to be emotionally vulnerable he
says i got my boys for that what could
you offer him
me personally yeah
i want to lie and say peace of mind
[Laughter]
i said that's a big value for me but but
do you know what yeah i'm learning i
don't mind being like honest yeah i'm
learning that sometimes we just need to
shut up as women
no no no
yeah
honestly like we need to shut up i like
i'm guilty of this because sometimes i
can get so emotional and i'm just like
wait hold on
it's not really that big of a deal let
me just take a step back
and i get more of a positive outcome
when i'm a little bit more logical with
a man that i'm romantically involved
with than when i'm all over the place
and then the second thing is listen
because oftentimes yeah men really are
telling us what the issue is what the
problem is and then we take a we take
like an asset
selectively
he's like but you've missed everything i
was trying to say
so peace of mind if we could do that we
could offer that
that a hoe and the other ones can't do
what do you guys think i do agree with
that i think listening is so important
because they will men will tell you yeah
and
more time you don't listen yeah yeah you
just don't because you you want to hear
what you want to hear yeah
suits you what makes you feel good
you feel me so
we don't listen that's very true i'm not
saying i'm not going to say everyone
because i'm
bombarded but
i think there's a big percentage of
women that don't listen we don't listen
and we talk on top of men as well we
talk over them
as well i think we need to allow men to
be men and women need to be women and i
think
that is something that's so important
there's too many women trying to be they
are trying to be men
that's me what do you
no that's i like you you're not you're
not alone that's like a common um role
of tomasi always says women become the
men they want to marry yeah so they get
good with their finances they get in
shape they do all the things that they
want yeah in a guy would you say yeah
that's what happened to me basically my
my relationship went down in the toilet
because
i was the man
like i wasn't even allowed them to pay
for a dinner or offer me a dinner
because i know i'll pay i'll do that you
want to go out on a weekend i'll pay how
long did i lost
well the last ones just six months
that's
yeah i know i know now
i went in that healing process yeah
oh [ __ ]
i'm going to make a point on that yeah i
did i didn't wet in spain i didn't wear
on a holiday with my girlfriend yeah
i just no i just know where they're
going
i think no i i didn't no no i just see
here london and i was like you know what
i think that something's wrong with me
it's not me that like it's not that
other people are
it's
accountability though that's me probably
i'm being a prick as well
so
i should work on myself and being honest
with me accept what are my limits
and what i should ill
might post traumas and
like choose up